the goal is to try to pass out in the  house that's what's gotten comfy usually  the shirt is easy cuz I get the most  excited about my shirts this one I  haven't worn this yet but we already  know how we're gonna pop that off trying  to find which jacket to you that takes a  minute I can be like heartily dressing  you're not knows he's just decided on  something that we've done before this is  something I've shot in tonight's just  like the perfect opportunity for it this  is GQ and this is a really unique outfit  my sunglass options are kind of crazy at  this for me and that's what it like it  comes all the way together we have the  jewelry you got the shirt without the  belt you got the pant is that the band's  you got the no socks we could I sleep  with my watch I'm sleeping everything  that's probably I'm liable to just fall  asleep just like this I ain't get a  moment cuz we party hard  you can't look this bad